Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui on va se demander
si Adam et Ève ont vraiment existé.
Alors rassurez vous, il ne va pas être question de
considérations religieuses ou créationnistes dans cette vidéo.
On va parler de génétique humaine
et on va voir que, en un certain sens,
Adam et Ève ont vraiment existé.
Juste, ils ne se sont jamais connus.
C'est une chose que vous savez certainement déjà,
l'information génétique est contenue
dans les chromosomes
et nous, les humains, on a 23 paires de chromosomes.
Je dis bien paires, puisqu'on a tous
deux exemplaires de chaque chromosome.
Deux exemplaires, sauf qu'il y a une exception
à cette règle, c'est la 23ème paire,
ce que l'on appelle les chromosomes sexuels.
Vous savez, les femmes possèdent
une paire de chromosomes X,
mais les hommes possèdent
un chromosome X et un chromosome Y.
Du coup le chromosome Y, quand il est là,
il est toujours tout seul dans son genre,
il n'est jamais associé dans une vraie paire.
Et il y a une conséquence intéressante de ça, c'est que
mon chromosome Y est exactement
le même que celui de mon père.
Et ça ce n'est pas vrai des autres chromosomes.
Prenons par exemple le chromosome 17.
Mon père possède deux exemplaires
du chromosome 17 dans chacune de ses cellules.
Un exemplaire hérité de son propre père
et un hérité de sa mère.
Et lors de la production des spermatozoïdes,
(mais ça marcherait pareil pour les ovules),
Il se produit un mécanisme qui va mélanger
ces deux chromosomes de manière aléatoire.
On appelle ça la recombinaison génétique.
La conséquence de ça, c'est que le chromosome 17
que je reçois de mon père, il est unique,
il est différent des siens et il est aussi
différent de ceux de mes grands-parents.
Et c'est ça le principe du brassage génétique.
Et ce mécanisme de recombinaison
existe pour tous les chromosomes,
sauf le chromosome Y puisqu'il n'a
personne avec qui se mélanger.
Du coup mon père m'a passé
son chromosome Y à l'identique.
Et il l'a passé aussi à mon frère qui, du coup,
a exactement le même chromosome Y que moi.
Mais du coup, ce chromosome Y c'est aussi
le même que celui de mon grand-père évidemment.
Et de mes oncles.
Et de mes cousins.
Et aussi de mes cousins au deuxième degré, etc...
Ce serait assez tentant de conclure que tous les hommes de la
planète doivent posséder exactement le même chromosome Y.
Mais en fait ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai.
La raison : c'est à cause des mutations génétiques.
Dans nos cellules, il y a des mutations
qui se produisent de manière aléatoire
et qui modifient légèrement la séquence de notre ADN.
Et donc on n'a pas tous exactement
le même chromosome  Y.
Ces mutations sont relativement rares,
on estime que entre 2 frères,
il doit y avoir en moyenne, en gros,
une mutation de différence sur le chromosome  Y.
Une mutation sur plusieurs
dizaines de millions de bases.
Et du coup entre moi et mes cousins il y a,
en moyenne, environ deux mutations de différence.
Et puis avec mes cousins au
2ème degré en moyenne 3 mutations.
Alors j'insiste, tout ça c'est en moyenne,
c'est-à-dire que c'est soumis aux lois du hasard.
Ce qui est intéressant c'est que si on prend
deux hommes au pif dans la population
et que l'on compte le nombre de différences
sur leurs chromosomes Y,
ça nous donne une idée de : à quel degré
ils sont reliés dans la généalogie.
Et si on fait ça pour tout un échantillon
représentatif de la population mondiale actuelle,
on peut avoir une idée
de : à quel degré on est tous cousins.
Ou bien une autre manière de le dire,
combien de générations nous séparent
de notre ancêtre commun en ligne directe.
Et si on fait ces analyses, (et là je le dis comme
si c'était facile, en fait ça ne l'est pas du tout),
on trouve que le mâle humain, ancêtre en ligne directe
de tous les mâles humains vivants à l'heure actuelle
il aurait vécu il y a environ 150 000 ans.
Et c'est cet individu qu'on appelle
"Adam chromosome Y"
Alors ce type d'analyse on peut
le faire aussi avec les femmes.
Mais pour la faire on ne va pas utiliser le chromosome X
puisque le chromosome X, il vient en paire,
c'est à dire qu'il va subir une recombinaison
et être complètement modifié à chaque génération.
On va utiliser autre chose
qu'on appelle l'ADN mitochondrial.
Les mitochondries ce sont des petits trucs,
en fait on dit des organites,
qu'on trouve dans presque toutes les cellules
et qui sont en quelque sorte
les centrales énergétiques de la cellule.
Et ce qui est assez amusant, c'est que les mitochondries
se comportent un peu comme une cellule dans la cellule.
Elles sont capables de se diviser et
elles ont leur propre ADN qui se réplique
mais qui est distinct de l'ADN normal
qu'on trouve dans le noyau des cellules.
Et c'est ça l'ADN mitochondrial.
Alors ce qui est intéressant pour nous,
c'est que vos mitochondries au départ,
elles proviennent entièrement de l'ovule de votre mère.
Au cours de la fécondation, normalement
le spermatozoïde ne file pas de mitochondrie.
Donc si vous êtes un homme,
votre ADN mitochondrial, il n'ira pas plus loin que ça.
Par contre, si vous êtes une femme, cet ADN
mitochondrial que vous avez hérité de votre mère
passera à vos enfants, et notamment à vos filles,
qui le passeront à leurs filles,
qui le passeront à leurs filles, etc...
Et donc l'ADN mitochondrial se transmet
intégralement de mères en filles,
de la même manière que le chromosome Y
se transmettait intact de pères en fils.
Sauf que, comme pour le chromosome Y,
la transmission, elle est pas parfaite,
il y a des mutations dans l'ADN mitochondrial.
Et donc, on peut faire le même
genre d'analyse que tout à l'heure.
Et ça nous amène à conclure que
toutes les femmes du monde, vivantes
à l'heure actuelle, elles descendent en ligne directe,
d'une femme, qu'on appelle "Ève mitochondriale"
et qui aurait vécu il y a environ 150 000 ans.
Bon donc, on a Adam, Ève, et ils auraient vécu
tous les deux il y a 150 000 ans, est-ce que...
Non mais je vous arrête tout de suite, ce n'est
pas du tout ce que vous croyez et on va voir pourquoi.
Il faut bien comprendre un truc dans cette affaire,
Il n'y a absolument aucune raison pour que
l'Adam chromosome Y et l’Ève mitochondriale, d'une,
se soient rencontrés et aient eu des enfants,
et de deux, aient simplement vécu au même moment.
Alors pour illustrer ça, on va prendre
un arbre généalogique simplifié.
Pour qu'il ne soit pas trop compliqué, il va être
un petit peu incestueux, mais vous allez voir
ça ne change rien au raisonnement.
Alors sur cet arbre super simple, vous voyez
des hommes en bleu, et des femmes en rouge.
Et il y a un homme, qui est
l'Adam chromosome Y de cet arbre,
c'est-à-dire l'ancêtre de tous les mâles
de la ligne du bas,
en ligne directe paternelle. Alors voilà, c'est lui.
Et on a aussi une Ève, c'est elle, qui est l'ancêtre
en ligne directe maternelle, cette fois,
de toutes les femmes de la dernière génération.
Et vous voyez qu'Adam et Ève dans cet exemple,
ils n'ont pas été en couple, ils n'ont pas eu d'enfant,
ils ne se sont pas rencontrés,
et ils ont même pu vivre
à des milliers de kilomètres de distance,
voire, carrément, à des époques différentes.
Et là j'ai pris un arbre très simple, mais
on peut très facilement construire des exemples,
où Adam et Eve sont séparés
par plusieurs centaines de générations.
D'ailleurs les datations que je vous ai données,
en fait elles ne sont pas si précises que ça.
Pour l'Adam Y, je crois qu'on estime en ce moment
que c'est entre 120 000 et 160 000 ans
et pour l’Ève mitochondriale
c'est plutôt entre 100 000 et 150 000 ans.
Alors quand même, le fait qu'on date l'Adam Y
et l’Ève mitochondriale, d'à peu près la même période,
ce n'est pas complètement surprenant.
Cette période, elle correspond à
l'émergence de notre espèce, homo sapiens,
mais avant sa sortie d'Afrique.
Alors pour tout ça, je vous renvoie
à ma vidéo sur le sujet.
Pour bien comprendre la différence
entre ces individus qu'on a appelé Adam et Ève,
et leurs homologues bibliques,
il y a plusieurs choses à noter.
La première, c'est que Adam Y n'était pas du tout
le seul homme de son temps.
De même, Ève mitochondriale n'était pas du tout
la seule femme de son temps.
D'ailleurs Adam Y avait un père,
et Ève mitochondriale avait une mère.
Et puis surtout, il faut bien comprendre que
ces individus ne sont pas des individus fixes, absolus.
On a dit ce sont les ancêtres en ligne directe des hommes
et des femmes, qui sont vivants à l'heure actuelle.
et donc leur identité va varier, en fonction
de la population vivante à un moment donné.
Si demain toute la population mondiale meurt,
sauf moi et mes cousins
et bien, mon grand-père devient l'Adam Y.
L'ancêtre, en ligne directe, de tous les hommes vivants.
En plus de ça, il faut voir que l'Adam Y
et l'Eve mitochondriale,
ce ne sont pas les seules manières
de nous définir un ancêtre commun.
Là on a parlé, des ancêtres communs,
en ligne directe paternelle et en ligne directe maternelle.
Mais on peut très bien parler de notre ancêtre commun
le plus proche, tout court.
Regardez sur mon schéma,
même si Adam est là et Ève est ici,
les ancêtres communs à la dernière génération,
qui soient les plus récents, et bien, ce sont eux.
Ils sont plus récents que Adam Y et Eve mitochondriale.
Et si on prend la population humaine actuelle
dans son ensemble,
on estime que notre ancêtre commun le plus récent,
il pourrait avoir seulement, quelques milliers d'années.
Ça veut dire, qu'il a existé un individu,
qui vivait probablement autour du Néolithique
et dont, tous les êtres humains
actuellement vivants sur terre, descendent.
Alors attention, ils ne descendent pas
que de lui, loin de là,
mais, en quelque sorte, on en a tous un petit morceau.
Enfin, le paradoxe c'est qu'à cause du phénomène
de recombinaison, il est possible qu'au final,
presque aucun des gènes de cet individu
ne soient parvenus jusqu'à nous.
Alors que, finalement,
l'Adam chromosome Y et l'Eve mitochondriale,
qui vivaient il y a bien plus longtemps
nous ont légué, plus ou moins intacts,
leur chromosome Y et leur ADN mitochondrial.
Et qui sait ? Peut-être que vous êtes
l'Adam Y ou l'Eve mitochondriale
de l'humanité qui peuplera la terre dans 150 000 ans.
Enfin pour ça, il va falloir
se mettre au boulot quand même.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo. Si elle vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à la partager
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne.
Vous pouvez suivre les actus de la chaîne
sur Facebook ou sur Twitter.
Ceux qui le souhaitent, peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee.
Comme d'habitude, je mets la liste
de tous les tipeurs à la fin de la vidéo.
Et vous pouvez aussi aller voir mon bouquin
qui est sorti chez Flammarion.
Merci et à bientôt.